masters one reykjavik is over and we
have our winners from na who took it all
home after two
weeks octagaming climbed their way to
the top and have crowned themselves our
current international champions and it
was pretty awesome but there's a lot
more to talk about than just n a in fact
we have the entire competitive valorem
scene to discuss and it might be a lot
deeper than you think
[Music]
all right guys it's liz back at it again
with another valentine video shocking
but don't forget to like button the
subscribe button and to ring the
notification bell we made it matches
reykjavik ended in pretty spectacular
fashion yesterday north america we still
have some life left in us yet i know
some of you were worried one of na's
most consistent teams optic who some of
you all might remember as envy was able
to raise the trophy above their heads
jay starts to address the sight first
fight found for crashes quick turn
didn't note anyone towards double doors
no way marge as well and el pancada
tournament life in your hands optic on
the verge and it's all but over it's
overdone
optic gaming build their legacy brick by
brick there's a couple things to
highlight about optics run they'll make
their win all the more impressive
remember optic are the team that have
come close but have never made it all
the way in fact we saw them get three
owed by gambit slash mech back at
masters 3 berlin as the saying goes
always the bridesmaid never the bride
optic fought back tooth and nail to make
it to the grand finals remember they
lost to the guard in the na challengers
final so they had to play all the way
through the group stage before the final
optic had won 214 rounds of valor during
this masters alone not played one just
that many rounds is exhausting by the
time they played zeta division in the
lower bracket final they had played 15
different maps in the tournament and you
know after we got the discussion of
cringe comps and weird insinuations
about people's financial situations out
of the way and a proper roasting on
twitter had ensued things ended up
working out for optic to understand just
how impressive this is well lao for
preparing for the grand final optic had
to play a best of five to make it to the
next best of five the grand final
basically this tournament asks this team
how deep can you dig how thick is your
strapbook and can you stay consistent
and we saw maps go back and forth with
huge leads lost and they still managed
to come out on top and yay was not going
to let anyone take that trophy away from
him okay
you're considered one of the best
players in the world and
now you have this trophy
in your hands how does it feel
oh good
i could spend entire videos talking
about marv's impact fns's shot calling
yay being yay victor on the neon and
crashes being the rock of the team but
we don't have time for that today the
impact each individual player had on the
team was a master class on how to play a
composition based game they did it damn
well this may sound like i'm huffing the
nakopium but you can't deny that optic
were crisp as hell and honestly i'm the
first to criticize an a because frankly
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm our biggest fan
and our biggest critic the first team i
would like to highlight besides optic is
zeta division you know coming into this
tournament really didn't give them as
much attention than say compared to team
liquid or even ninjas in pajamas but boy
oh boy did they deliver in nice fashion
after falling to drx first they pushed
and pushed until they reached optic in
the lower finals and found themselves on
the losing end but what made this team
so great is their reads they never took
any space for granted and they were
reading teams like a picture book
another team that we have to talk about
here are the demon kings of paper rex
and if you think of being facetious here
just watch this clip and tell me you do
not get us hyphas pens
oh
absolutely sensational paper rex brought
out the yoru the raina and the most
disrespectful rays you will ever see
whether it is in pro play or just our
pathetic ranged games jing on the reina
should not come as a surprise we've seen
him on it before and as we can tell he
absolutely delivered i think all of us
kind of had this hitch in our breath you
know like arena and professional play
surely not but i said it after the haven
game i will literally never doubt arena
in professional play again one of my
favorite interview moments happened when
i interviewed mind freak and i asked him
how he prepped for g2 to which he simply
replied our coach like
uh tell us like just go take a nap go to
your room now to be honest like we
didn't prepare anything and of course we
need to talk about our brazilian super
team loud who placed second overall
after losing the optic in the grand
final i mean i would be absolutely
terrified to face loud in the future the
tenacity and flexibility of that team
are so scary after forming in february
they've only lost once and it was in
those grand finals to optic a team they
had already beat their precision is part
of the italian me chef's kiss they are
clinical their aim is sublime there's oh
my god they are so good bro oh my god
and there's no point having good aim
without the brains to back it up but
these guys do they have the best of both
worlds now these are our top four teams
from this event and challengers is just
around the corner at least for n a and
there have been so many different roster
shake ups honestly been kind of hard to
keep track of and it's literally what i
am paid to do but optic have shut up the
haters that have said na is dead after
our reason floundering and even better
in my opinion is that in this event the
top four teams were all from different
regions aipac japan brazil and n a are
we witnessing the dawn of a truly
international esport one where any team
from anywhere can take home the trophy
i hope so because if so the future of
valorance seems so
so bright
chuck those worries aside
damn
i don't know why i did that okay i have
a little thing there when i do that like
[Music]
i came up with that sentence myself i
thought it was super cute let me know if
you think that sentence cute colton
sentence did you like that sentence
colton
he's gonna say no isn't he